نتحدث عن توقعات الفائزين في الاحد في
الحدث الاهم سينمائيات حفل الاوسكار في
دورته الخامسه وتسعين نبدا اولا عن الفئات
الرئيسيه الفئات الرئيسيه او اولا شنو
فيلمك المفضل هالسنه كان
انا فيلم اللي حبيته حبيت افاتار عن جد
بت
منى
ما كتير يعني
حبيت ابشرك لانه كسر الارقام
مع بعض
95 وانما
ممكن ان يحصد بالاسكار لهذا العام عن فئه
افضل فيلم اما افضل ممثله هي شبه محسومه
لكيد بلانشيت من
افضل ممثل هي بين برندن فيسر من ويلز
وايضا اللي هو اللي قام بدور الفيسبريسلي
فانا اعتقد عاده
10,000 شخص هم دائما يميلون الاشياء لها
علاقه بالبايوغرافي فلهذا السبب اعتقد
حظوظ شوي اعلى من براندن فريزر اما
الافلام الانيميشن شبه محسومه لفيلم
بينوكيو يعني فاز بكل الجوائز اللي تسبق
حفل الاوسكار اما الممثلين اللي بدور
مساعد الممثل بدور مساعد اكيد راح يكون
من افيتنج ايفري وير اول اتوانس وايضا
بدور مساعده راح يكون لانجله بسيط
واكيد راح نوجهك بكره بهذه النتائج
لم يكن يعني الصراحه
كان عباره عن قصص بالفيلم بس كان جدا رائع
يعني وجهه نظر